uh so topic of today's lecture is
pretty much um
fishers and games we will discuss
several engines
played by fisher some of them i mean all
them were very interesting
most of them you know really really
impressive
uh in some of them however i found some
crazy discovery so we will look at that
too
[Music]
anyway so let's let's get started
so 10 of you in the chat great and
so uh yeah let's get started so
officials and games
hello peter paul romania
from saint louis greetings from saint
louis
how do i pronounce pronounce my name
exactly
that's how you say it exactly in polish
however americanized
very version of darius is also fine
um all right
so uh we're gonna start uh by talking
uh about this game
i think it's a thing good place to start
so uh this is the game between uh fisher
and roshevsky
you i think you know this game great
some of the games are very famous
so i wouldn't be surprised if you know
many many of them
but i'm pretty certain that you don't
know some of them
anyway uh let's uh let's get started
they play many times that's true they
play many times so uh
here i would i wanted to start
discussing
pretty much
this position uh
so yeah uh fisher was playing with white
uh
black black was playing uh roschevsky
so let's evaluate
who do you guys uh think is better here
how old were both players uh at the time
i think
fisher was around 20
around maybe 19 and roshasky was older
but
how old exactly he was
you want to say white okay
yeah i've been using for some time
leeches for you know classes here and
in general for for kind of like lectures
and stuff
uh the question is who is better here
white or black or equal also could be
equal
well yeah 1960s er you know 70s
i mean i think kartharov wrote a book
about the revolution
the theory in 1970s and
[Music]
yeah back then
you know the theory wasn't that
developed yet
and uh which healthy it's also
charm i would say
hey steve
well i think knowing games of fisher is
definitely worth it because it's good
you know he was like really really
one of the best in history ever so
he's definitely important to know his
games
like this one for instance um okay
so okay so majority of you say it's
white is better and i
pretty much agree with it so uh yeah
white is better
white rooks are a little bit better uh
and another thing is that
y has much better pawn structure
[Music]
you know even if um i mean i mean black
has more responsibility
is definitely a weakness uh pawn on d6
potentially could be a weakness however
i don't see if i actually don't think
the point is is too much of a
weakness let's say if this pawn on h7
was only h7 but let's say will be on f7
i don't think black would have had any
trouble to be honest with phone h7
uh you know because points is sort of
like a backward pawn but we can't attack
it in any way
like it's well defended by the king and
the bishop and we'll just play
rook with the root of any of the rook if
we want to um
you know i don't think that it makes uh
such a big deal here in person to spawn
d6 but pawn h7 on the other hand
yes this is definitely a weakness and
as we will see shortly this was um
a really big problem in this game for uh
for aschevsky
so uh why why to play this position why
official play with king e2
very logical um you know improving the
king slightly
fate bishop e3 rook c8 basically black
white black is forced to be defending
very passively there is no active plan
here for
for um for black
so
so what do you think guys uh what what
should how
should white continue here there are
many good plans but uh can you play like
fisher
basically there is only one weakness
right so
uh the role the general rule in such end
games should be to create second
weakness
and avoid sort of you know rushing
things which is a rule i already talked
last time about
who do not hurry in certain games we can
basically
sort of uh there is no need to basically
suddenly
trade pawns you know or like you know
for instance f4 if anyone wants to
suggest f4 is possible
it is premature in my opinion
c4 to prevent b5 well if you play c4
uh i would say that i may
at some point actually play b5 maybe
even right away
uh because if then
you take well they always will see two
routes b2 i'll have ideas
so this is i wouldn't be so sure if you
play c4 i'll always have an
idea of b5 in order to uh
challenge your pawn structure and get
some counter play
uh peter suggest b4 b5 and yes
before b5 is the best idea right now uh
before b5 the idea of b4 is to play b5
and create begin creating second
weakness
and actually it appears that it's not
easy to deal with
this thread because if b5 follows then
palm b7 will be chronically weak and a5
will be opened
so um you know seeing that roshowski
decided to play b5 himself
but b5 you know the point of before is
to
actually provoke b5 because but you know
why is good
doing good either way either white plays
b5 and
you know cree creates maybe
sorry weakness on a6 or b7
or provokes b5 uh with close position
but still pawn a6 is a weakness so here
roshan decided to go
uh for b5 but other wants to quickly
illustrate let's say
after i know king e6 or something let's
say something like this
also wouldn't be wouldn't be pleasant
let's say rook a1 and basically the
influence will infiltrate from this side
this uh
you know white dominates on both sides
of the board
and uh i think this you know is not
really helping so
he said so before was very good idea and
right now erosky played b5
and right now i think it's remarkable
how fisher was playing this because
okay engines are just here like white is
winning in many ways but
on human level it's not entirely clear
why why why would be winning
it's only you know uh not even extra
pawn pretty much it's not even an extra
pawn
only uh some strategic let's say
advantage positional advantage but the
computer claim is just plus five or
something
or is this some nuts evaluation which is
uh
surprising but let's see how in human
terms like in
from human perspective how fisher was
winning this he played first move right
now rook d1
rogue retreats rook has a job on d5
threaten b5
right now the rook doesn't do anything
so right now the idea of rook d1 is to
play either rook h3 and rook
rook dh1 or rook a1 and double on the a
file
and uh you know right now we do not
declare yet what we're gonna do
uh king six is very logical and now we
go this way rookie one goes from this
side
uh rook c6 yes black has rook c6 and you
know seemingly everything is fine
pawn a6 is defended pawn h7 is defended
if any from either side of why black
sorry white rooks double then black also
will
support you know the weakness seemingly
you know hard to make progress you
provide but let's see what happens
uh there's the point uh in such
positions we cannot hurry with there is
no
need to rush decisions and we just
slowly slowly advance uh
i mean gradually improve our position
and yes through h3 is what uh
fischer played very nice i money uh rook
h3 idea right now rook
h1 the from pawn h7 is clearly weak
because uh
right now if we play rogue one next move
actually pawn h7 is just lost
would there be no way to defend this
pawn so uh roshasky leadership f8
and uh idea is to have idea of course of
rook c7
uh so this is what happened hi roger one
rook c7
and right now uh fischer played move
rook h4 so idea of ruger h4
it's hard to understand i think
but uh can you find a move actually here
for black can you find a
kind of like good move here for black
and once you answer this question we
will figure out why
rook h4 is just so strong
this is the best example of the rule
do not hurry
can black do anything here what can what
can we pause what could black possibly
do here
it doesn't stop d5 still defense still
can be played
h4 doesn't stop d5 d5 actually happen in
the game
so it doesn't stop d5
okay elias bowman's uh rook f7 you
suggested so what happens after rook f7
what would what will white do after rook
f7
well if age six i was just capture it
right
just take stage h6 just takes
i don't know he seems like he's just
winning
i don't know i i don't like it for black
the advances tactics yes black is in
such funk
that's correct basically black in this
position is suddenly it sucks when there
is no good move
look if you ask yourself what where to
put this bishop at like here or here but
then
uh upon history we just lost
yeah after h6 white's black white simply
winning i money
so we can also bishop so we should we
can move that bishop
we cannot move the rook because if only
square and then we simply win the h7
pawn
uh what about the king if it goes
anywhere here
also each standpoint is lost if we touch
this pawn
uh of course we either either after h6
or h5
we play gtx h6
if a5 we just take it it's over
so uh what about this rook where it were
and the question the thing is that
if rook goes here pawn on h7 is lost
white simply wins the spawn h7 and rogue
goes let's say here also the same thing
happens
if rook goes anywhere on the seventh
rank let's say
here right now white can play rook a1
and suddenly bishop from e3 covers a 7
square so the rook can
go back and suddenly pawn on a6 is lost
and wide winds so therefore d5 is the
only move in this position
but after d5 it already weakens
significantly
the position and we'll see why
so uh actually
yeah right now okay white play rook day
one i want to ask you some question i
will in a second
but right now follow rook a1 rook c6 and
e takes d5 king to xd5 okay so uh how
would you continue right now with what
nick glassen yeah exactly exactly
ivrook was going on the seventh ranked
rook a one and a six points gone
so but in this position why to play how
can you further increase you know
advantage
and some put some more pressure
this is why to play right now
last move was king trace d5
okay so there are a few suggestions uh
f4
alias balmana f4
is i think the
i don't know strategically definitely
unsound
one of the i don't know
moves that i wouldn't consider sort of
here because uh f4
uh you know just a sim list of
simplifications when you're defending
uh it's simply simplifications are good
for you right now we are attacking with
white so we don't want to
trade pawns we want to keep as many
posts as possible on the board and
create some weaknesses
only five could be weakness we don't you
don't know that uh
another idea was uh rook a5 and with the
pawn rook if i i'm
not sure how it wins the pawn i'll just
go back in e6 i don't know
what's happening then no rogue a5
king just e6 and black is okay i mean
relatively of course
and finally king d3
uh king d3 it's possible
well let's say okay better than rook a5
and f4 definitely
but rook d8 and rook d rook d1 rook d8
as suggests and then
king lear followed up
rook d1 rook d8 is by far the best
position but
by far the best move improves the
position of the rook the most
pins on the back rank and uh you know
makes total i mean like makes uh
you know black pistol like cramped
that's what fischer played rook d1 this
is activity
uh the most important thing k6 rook d8
basically became getting a rogue from
behind
the king f5 followed and now rook a8
putting the pressure on this uh pawn a6
so
the rope was here and we re-routed it
towards a8 so basically also attacks
here but the same
apart from attacking point six also pins
here
so uh it's much better place on a than
it was on the a1 right
so in the game for simply rook e6 black
has to simply wait
and now rock h3 suddenly look at 3 we
just drew atom 2 in the piece
and it appears that you know sooner or
later
white will you know get this rook f3 or
rook to f3 anyway because if for
instance e4
we can play at least rook f4 with value
h4 value f4 so uh
[Music]
you know uh why not rook to a1 because
irrigate three friends to win the piece
what if bishop c5 if bishop c5 uh
i think maybe i have this
let's see if this is the position we are
talking about but
okay if yeah so that's why rook h3
remove this rook from
here and further look at three so in the
game follow simply bishop g7
uh you know roshasky decided just to
give up the pawn
but uh
yeah right now rook takes h7 and grabs
his pawn points and paulie six is still
a weakness rg8 has to be played and now
uh check check again
and finally the move that you suggested
a long long time ago
king d3 king comes to play kinky four
and the white is just just totally
winning
essentially fischer didn't do anything
kind of like
forcing in his end game he just kind of
like naturally you know
slowly improve his position and he
black's defense is collapsed
uh bishop c5 earlier i don't know when
earlier because i
see i saw only one moment when you could
play bishop c5
here but then king to hg5 i don't know
what's happening maybe you can
move your rook back or something but
then just go here or something
you lost g5 pawn you're not winning any
pieces you know like
i'm not sure
okay so uh this is how the game ended
pretty much because after
did he grab this h7 pawn rook f7 king
g4 uh f3 king comes to d3
decide to give up the e4 pawn this this
bishop d4 he can
just do extra pawns this totally winning
and they played few more moves and but
you know the result
was never in in doubt and
yeah we should have six and finally nice
move rook e1
basically e7 follows and the game is
over
so this is how uh
fisher managed to win this game
all right so uh the next example would
be probably a little bit more famous
game
i mean this was also i think were pretty
well known but uh let's look at the next
one
uh which is a fisher petrossian that i
wanted to show
probably many of you know this game
[Music]
so
let's start from here
so let's start from here last two moves
were like uh queen takes the f4 knight
xa4
so this position um white is clearly
better
obviously a nice advantage you know
either why black has isolated pawn and
white has bare bone structure
still blacking is still you know in the
center police's
potential can become also a weakness you
know
what is what's better depends how the
question is how much better of course
but
no doubt that white is trying to push
here for a win
so right now we're black to play in
this position fredros i'm playing with
bishop v6 which is very logical
you know he wants to either castle or do
something with the spin on the e file
so uh yeah in this position what kind of
plan would you choose here for white
what would you play with white here and
with what plan
you
g5 maybe maybe advance the ab
pawns
okay all this possible obviously
anyone else
because you didn't suggest yet what uh
i think at least and with what fischer
played is the best
rook six free bishop is not three bishop
iphone is on f7
g5 is good b75 is definitely a good move
i can tell you that but
i don't like it as much it as much as
i like you know what fisher played
for rook c1 f4 uh okay
so there are many suggestions here let's
look at that
uh basically okay what i the the most
most mostly you were suggesting bishop
g5 so
and the idea of regression one knight c5
so let's see what happens
[Music]
um
i think i could play rook ca but i can
see that i can't
um oh maybe it'll b8
and for instance if you go b3 i'm gonna
play a5 the point is that if i go if we
go
even this i might try to do this this
and play a4 try to simplify the position
i don't care at all about bishop take
this which is
good for me i will be happy if this
happens also i have an idea as
always of playing in this position maybe
even right now knight e4
so after this this uh you know even if
you take this pawn i'll be always
i'll always have sufficient condo play
here by playing uh
a4
so um i am not entirely
okay it's possible to play like this of
course white is still you know slightly
better i'm not you know
it's not like it's bad or anything but
uh
i'm not i'm not entirely sure whether
this is the best
way to go ideas of a four house are
interesting
uh you know yeah they're also
interesting
i think but anyway i was just after
fallback g6 i don't think it changes too
much
uh i don't think it changes too much
let's say i go g6 and i don't know
but it's possible of course uh but none
of you suggested
i think what in general is the best idea
which is to trade those bishops
because without those bishops all dark
squares are extremely weak
we get to free easily get our knights to
c5 as you guys
want it and this knight there will be
very very strong
that's why we should be free this will
happen in the game we should be free
ideas to play with bishop c5
and trevor's bishop instead bishop
install the dyno c5 and
go after the weak a6 phone
make sense
all right i'll assume it makes sense
okay so in the game for a short castle
so um
right now following the plan bishop c5
c5 yeah so seems like basic right
seems like basic but uh
i mean it doesn't really stop from
castling uh black and castle either way
after anything almost
what if bishop before harassing the rook
uh good question i will just remove my
rook
and the play bishop sorry bishop is
bishop c5 either way
or even maybe now sorry a3 before as
well
where would black lose the pawn
i don't know what you mean by money
yeah okay so basically this idea seems
basic right okay just develop that
bishop
nothing extraordinary sometimes you know
moves are
uh the the best moves are not really
complicated
this is kind of like you know improve
their pieces like you know
where they feel like they are you know
well placed uh
you know we should be free you know very
logical
c5 also logical the kind of
beauty of fisheries play i think is that
very often he wasn't doing
like two difficult moves he just come
make it look very simple
uh but in reality it's not that simple
you kind of like see the depth of it
and especially in this game uh you know
when he played one of the moves uh that
was uh
you know i'm very famous
so i would i wouldn't be surprised if my
if many of you know them no
this game to start with so okay
okay so leif carmen
carmen uh in this position after a short
castle
okay first of all after bishop's five
version becomes uh
is several very similar to whatever was
whatever happened in the game this is
one thing
second thing after rook c8 i can play
with knight this is
uh i think it is a little bit stronger
yes
so um in the game because i don't i'll
be extremely strong
and after 95 you're not even creating
any i mean you're creating maybe three
attacking on a6 but you don't want to
take on e6
so i guess i can maybe do something
about it
um also if there could be some
tendencies like to take and play knight
e4 or something in
some lines uh i wouldn't be so sure but
the bishop's fire is definitely a good
okay good move rookie 8 bishop b7
takes and
what would you play right now this is
actually a very important position
yeah pretty much how to make this back
to bring my knight to c5 how to make
this happen
okay two suggestions here knight c5 and
b4
all right so which one is
better what what do you guys think 95 is
not a move it's not
legal to play 95 in this position
rooks or rook ac1 also possible
chess king you such as rook ac one
before a3 knight c5 okay but if you do
all of these moves i'll also do
something with black right
let's see five okay my c5 majority of
you still suggest knight c5
some of you suggest move b4
knight b6 thing for suggestion
again b4
f4 okay
okay more more people building towards
b4
and yes b4 is the best move b4 is the
best move and
let's understand before why b4 is the
best move so basically
police is a weakness and by playing
before we are fixing this weakness the
disabilities will be there we are making
sure that this weakness is there
because after before if ever black plays
a5
and this is what imani said
[Music]
we do not play a3 right now a3 would be
a mistake
maybe not the miss no the big mistake
but let's say inaccuracy
we can play just b5 we can create
immediately a pass pawn well
when uh we can support it let's
stabilizer by first of all it's
supported by the bishop on d3
we can maybe play a4 in the future but
after we move this knight let's say to
c5 or something
you know rooney c1 is coming or maybe
even rook ab1 would support his pawn
maybe this pawn can easily go forward
quickly uh b5 uh you know after a5 we
always want to push to have the past
pawn
so after before uh you know right now
pawn lasik
is a weakness it's just becoming a
weakness and
[Music]
it is not easy to get rid of it the
problem for instance with moonlight c5
is that right now a5 points on the dark
square it will be easily attacked
and to be honest yes white is better but
the
i think the voice advantage is pretty
much limited
and you know it is it would be
pretty hard especially with player like
petrossian who was playing with black
with such a great defender
to break through here so that's why uh
fischer play move b4 to fix the weakness
on a6
and make sure that this pawn become
you know will be a target in the future
i miss something in chat
okay so um same thing after
c1 by the way just a5 and this is not
not so clear anyway that's why b4 is a
very good move
in the game for just king of eight makes
sense to bring the king to the center
uh you know king has to be always
and gains fear and feel more in engage
king should come to the center so it
feels natural to play like that
and okay someone suggests uh life carmen
after knight c5 a5 bishop f5 looks nice
okay but i'll just go to a hero g8 i
just defend
and uh
and i'm i'm good just king it was the
idea yeah uh
but it's it was correct idea but i think
that you started the wrong move
if i'm not mistaken because you and
ma is basically pretty much to start uh
pretty much
very important to start with fb4 right
now
okay king of eight knight c5
right now when it comes to c5 you can
see the opponent is is a big weakness
so a5 of course is met by b5
so uh patricia decided to play move
bishop ca try to defend this pawn
passively
i mean hard to judge him for this move
uh you know paulus is a big weakness so
he's somewhat defended
f3 logical if rook to acquire rook to z1
doesn't change much now we only control
the e file
and you know it politics still remains a
big weakness
what is clearly better so
right now patricia said play rook a
e7 rook e87 i mean and
try to over protect there's this pawn
and maybe improve his bishop somehow
for instance this could be an idea if he
could basically bring this bishop back
to the game by playing bishop december
cb5
to reverse bishops you know maybe pawn
on a6 will not be such a bad
pawn after all if we activate this
bishop to b5
right f3 is logical uh because uh
similarly to what black is doing by
playing king of a we also we need to
bring our king to the center of king f2
king in the end games need two kings
into n games need to play as well
that's why it's logical
[Music]
we will get there we will get there
gfceman
why not to trade and bring another rule
okay great question after take take
rookie one bring another rook king comes
to d6 son king becomes very active
we don't want this king to be active and
on the other hand if
in this position after f3 black wants to
take on on iran
okay we'll be very happy to take anyway
our is coming to the game
but this king remains on the king side
passive
that's the big difference f
well why not f4 you've asked me asking
lots of questions but it's great
i'm glad to answer i'm going to answer
all of them i know the 4.
f4 is also possible i'm not saying it's
impossible
but okay we can a little bit e4 square
in some lines maybe some simplifications
maybe some maybe some
simplifications will occur on the square
for instance i can i can play maybe
should be seven at some point not now
yet
of course we'll lose the piece but maybe
at some point maybe bishop
will come let's say maybe this way
knight d4 will follow let's say
with some simplifications also whenever
this king comes after
sorry after f4 to uh king f2
maybe i used g4 sometimes you know no
need to allow this no need to allow this
again then do not hurry there is it's
not who faster wins the game
is but who wins the game in the end
exactly takes the square footage from
the knight those two squares f3
and the control g squares right
um so yeah
in the game of okay foreign mission b5
and
right now uh fischer play move rook e5
and now uh bishop d7 so what would you
play right now with white
why to play in this position
okay so you need to ask yourself what is
the idea of bishop d7 about black
playing right now we should listen
what is black's idea right now
i showed it like few minutes earlier
yes basically blacks oh sorry uh as i
saw show in this from this picture right
now on this diagram
a bishop decimation before is black's
idea so after rookie 5
bishop d7 black side black's idea is to
play in this position bishop b5
so we got two options right now to stop
bishop b5 because
let's say we play rook a1 let's say then
bishop b5 we
also never want to take because then
those are the f i would just capture a
two pawn
so we have to retreat some of the c to c
two and then okay paul rox can retreat
going back go back to the center
maybe even rook c84 by a5 will be
possible
so uh you know this is you know not so
not so clear maybe rook c7 is more
accurate
that this is of you know largely less
important
and uh but here so there are two moves
a4
to start now bishop b5 y has two moves
a4 and knight takes d7
so which one would you play such as a4 i
can see
okay so here is the thing a4 is the most
natural move
is the most natural move that everyone
would play
but fisher and uh
you know a4 i think i read some analysis
about this
this position i didn't realize myself it
too deeply but uh
it's still worth it to show you know how
this is so this i guess for this game
you know uh the i didn't read some
analysis about
some of some articles about this endgame
that
basically was proven that a4 was
objectively the best move
as long as i ran my engine briefly for
like a few minutes and stuff
and you know both moves lead to huge
advantage for white so i wouldn't be
kind of like so sure whether a4 kind of
like okay it's my
very cautious let's say guess right now
that a4 is
so much better than other of course a4
is you know very very good of course
why not why because why wouldn't it be
basically polynesia is a big weakness
and we make sure we establish a b5
uh we maybe want to play a5 because then
b5 wouldn't be that great because we'll
have passport on a5 right
and the pawn on uh you know ac is a big
weakness
we want to improve the rook then knight
on c5 is so great why would we ever
trade it for this passive bishop on d7
right all those points are valid totally
correct
white is much much better but uh
let's let's see what fisher did he play
move knight takes d7
he played knight takes d7 and this is
sort of transformation of the advantage
uh what he did right now is basically he
gives away his very strong knight for or
his opponent's bad bishop
you know no no wonder i mean no doubt
about it bishop is very bad
but he uh he he transforms his advantage
right now after
of course knight takes he wins the pawn
there's one thing but
after rook takes e7 right now he can
play move rook c1
and he right now controls the c5 he
wants to invade with through c6
boneless is a big weakness
uh you know he wants to basically he
just wants to
win the a6 pawn and also was important
to note that fisher realized that knight
on f6 is a very bad piece
and it's uh you know our his bishop i
think
in general fischer prefer bishops
overnight
and you know uh you know
bishop on d3 is very strong is much
better than i don't know 6 which is
first of all restricted as you guys can
see
uh you know the face with pawn f3 right
is restricted
it cannot go really anywhere and uh you
know
rook city is coming and if rook leave
leaves seven of rings let's say rook d6
which will happen in the game
right now group comes to c7
you know rook any will come those rooks
are right now
very very strong and still black has
very little counterplay
little to none so pretty much because
after a5 b5 follows
and you know white has clear advantage
so in this position
okay let me read some chart
yeah pretty much i mean yeah like knight
67 eliminates this bishop that
potentially could become active and this
is pretty much true because knight has
very little chance of getting active
because you know it's very very very
well restricted so okay
uh let's let's see what happens rook c7
knight d7
logical rugby two we have to get
our look back g6 king f2
uh h5 you know basically black is forced
to passive defense right now
uh up to a point because there's one
moment where black basically could have
uh made some better move because fisher
made one mistake in this game
uh king f2 uh h5 f4 very logical right
now after h5 has been played
we can play move f4 because first of all
knight is not already not on f6
is one thing and second thing we may
want to play f5 when we want to play
king of three and basically start
pushing pause on the kings as well
creating second weakness
you guys can see that on the queen side
there is one weakness but
usually that's how it works that uh you
cannot win with all
or your open having only one weakness so
basically he started creating second
wheels on the king's side
so uh k4 is very good move h4
but right now i think
uh i think uh after i i think i heard
what happened because basically everyone
was in shock and stuff
uh but uh you know no no doubt about it
uh but i if i'm wrong you can tell me if
you can change what happened
because i'm not really familiar with
that much i was just thinking that from
what
i kind of recalled everyone was super
surprised
anyway uh in this position why to play
and
play byron fisher
because he he made right now a move that
gave basically
some chances to petrossian to save the
game of course white black is still
struggling
like crazy in this position but um
basically with this move he could have
nearly won the game
right away okay it's not like you know
you know still game will go on but
white would
[Music]
pretty much be
you know winning
okay a4 a4
okay it's possible
chest king you will go h3 stop all age
freak under play
uh well i don't think there is such a
big counterplay with this h3 move and
stuff
we will just grab the pawn would be just
extra pawn
once i'm missing something
rook d2 f5 a freedom king of three
rookie three
king of three okay so uh
okay fischer played move king of three
so you some of you played like fisher
it's also very
you know good move but it give okay it's
not
okay it's a little bit inaccurate it's a
good move but it's definitely inaccurate
it is clearly an inaccuracy
because after king of three suddenly
petrossian
has some chances to save the game
f5 uh simplifications to pretty much
your simplification this after f
or after f5 uh you i can play maybe even
g5
i don't want to but wait have f5 gtx f5
to start with after f5 which is x5 you
play baseball i go rogue f6 and i trade
my
trailer bishop for my knight and i
simplify the position and i have better
chance to save the game with less pieces
on the board
just to show what i mean after this this
this i play rook f6
i give this but i take this and in this
band game you know
i raised some simplifications and i i
think that black can
save the game um
what's wrong with g4 nothing wrong with
g4 nothing wrong with g4
but it's not the not the best move so no
one ever suggested this move and i would
like to show you the move because i also
one game to show you
today so the best move right now is
rook c2 basically finally
oh i money correct rook c2
uh rook c2 i used to play rook c6
and basically pawn ace is just
collapsing
bonus is just spawn on this is just
collapsing and basically
uh white wins so uh
the thing is that after king f3
after king f3 there is one chance that
uh
i think patricia had and he didn't take
advantage of his chance because of
course
king of three comes with an idea of king
of king g4 fall back into his h4
oh you did say this in the beginning i
missed this in the chat sorry about that
i apologize
uh anyway uh king g4 king king takes h4
it seems like you know the good idea
right now for a while and that's why uh
patricia i'm playing
f5 which is a big mistake because it
weakens everything it work and weakens
you know entire position
and right now after when they follow
king free and king comes to d4
uh if give if given a chance and because
and if not given a chance then uh king
d14 d2
uh you know k i mean d4 k2 everything is
just
becoming like you know extremely weak
most importantly seven frame becomes
very weak and after move like knight b6
uh you know another comes to e7 and
basically it takes
takes uh you know just you know invades
and uh you know rook f7 rook h7 and
made made ideas it's basically very very
bad
and this is how the game ended actually
after 95 okay f7
simply root b7 and finally bishop c4 and
here
uh petrossian resigned which
is understandable because you know it's
just just lost those rooks on the
seventh rank are
just completely dominating
so well let's see in this position what
could have he played
after king f3 and okay i i would
normally ask you to what to do here but
i think we have to i have to show you
because there is one more game i will
really like to show you
uh knight b6 knight b6 was the best move
suddenly
and the point is that ideas of rook e7
or something like that uh
our med start with by rook f6 so nothing
really happens
and we need to somehow activate this
knight which somehow activate this
knight without activating design we can
just resign
and this is you know the game ends like
few moves after f5 like six moves and
the game was over but ibc was still
somewhat um you know
[Music]
more i don't know resilient
so that's why uh knight b6 had to be
played and the point is that after king
g4
uh black can play d4 basically look for
contour they activate this knight
somewhere knight comes to d5 after this
knight takes d5
kind of like triple fork and position
becomes extremely complicated
i don't think black is any worse anymore
so you have to activate this nice
somehow even when you have bad position
try to find you know the moves that
improve your uh
pieces because if you don't improve your
pieces they will remain bad and
you know you will not have you'll not
have you will not lose well and you
fight pretty much
so that's why you know for playing ib6
and this position was critical
knight b6 and france analyzed a little
bit but i didn't find anything
particularly let's say clear
here to how to play here you know with
fight for win
so uh for instance rook ec2 uh
after rook ec2 for instance i can play
d4
uh rookie seven uh rookie seven rook f6
i just go collect
i just cover here and again i want to
somehow improve my knight
by playing d4 presumably
not so clear not so clear so
[Music]
what i wanted to say is that let's say
rook c2 in this position
is already not that great a little bit
too late because i
i'll play d4
and after let's say i'm sorry after
let's say rook c6
i can play just rook d8
so this is let's say i can go to d8 and
again my knight comes to d5 so only way
to play this
was uh to activate this knight and of
course white is better
clearly better but you know things are
coming becoming a little bit less clear
let's say from practical reason from
practical point of view there are some
practical chances that
pedersen could have had in these games
too he didn't do it and he lost game
very quickly because he played
f5 and uh
you know after king freaking the two and
then afternoon v7
it's a little bit too late now for 96
because right now everything is weakened
on 7th rank and the game is just over
uh when the solutions club stream like
this
grand master lessons are on lectures i
mean are
every every
wednesday and thursday and also on
sundays or kids classes
um you can just check the web should
check the schedule on this english
website okay uh so the last game i
wanted to quickly uh
kind of like running out of time uh but
okay let's still do it let's still do it
let's still do that because i really
am i'm you know would like to do it let
me show you this game
so the game ulman fisher less known game
uh less known game definitely uh way
less known game but i'll ask you let's
see maybe two or three questions from
this end game because i find
extremely instructive and i was shocked
when i was analyzing it and preparing it
for today
so uh
in so this position so actually let's
flip the board
we are interested right now from black's
perspective fischer won this game with
black
but okay position is just roughly equal
so in the game for f5 trying to open the
center get some
game and get some play and so on so um
in this position uh you know um
decided to take which is not a bad
decision alternative was played
after f takes e4 just king e3 and you
know even though we are down upon
you know these pawns are doubled and it
pretty much doesn't matter
but positions after king g7 let's say or
something that is still just equal
i don't think any anyone has any chances
here so
any spec you know any great chance to
win the game it just should be a draw in
the end
but it takes a five followed which is
also okay she takes
five and now uh you know i think uh uma
made some somewhat
some small mistake because he played
roulette and put after ud2
seemingly you know decent move but his
position deteriorates quite
quickly and substantially the best move
was rook c3 basically activate the rook
for the third rank and basically go
go towards those let's say squares let's
say this this
this or this basically look for active
counterplay root e2 is a little bit too
passive
but okay still is not what i want to
talk about
here too much still it's quite okay
let's see free just trading everything
and we got this end game so um
actually let's just flip it from wise
perspective
uh
black is somewhat better here black is
somewhat better
let me explain black is somewhat better
here because
there are pawns on the the two sides of
the board
black has central pawns and black has a
bishop versus
and white has a knight so in positions
with bishop versus knight when pawns are
different on the different sides of the
board
it is usually better to have the bishop
and because because of that
simply black is slightly better here
however with correct defense the game
should obviously end with a draw
so uh right now the best defense for
white
was to play uh okay what he did was
correct uh
man with white still b4 was fine b6 but
right now you he had to pretty much play
with kinky free
and after king e3 you know position of
course is with slightly better for black
and separation b6 just king d3
and you know uh sorry bill basically d3
uh if king of c you can just play g
free and somehow you know just stay
together hold it together
of course white black has some chances
you know maybe you
go from the try to go from the king side
maybe go back to the center maybe you
know attack spawn c4 here and there
it of course black still has some
practical chances but with correct
defense white definitely should uh
uh should you know defend this
uh however
however this is not what ullman played
we won't play with a4 it was a big
mistake
suddenly uh policy on c4 is a
target and this is exactly where fisher
capitalized on
on this mistake he played
bishop e6 and pawn c4 is right now uh in
trouble he cannot easily defend it so
he plays c5 but sorry i will slip this
back
b takes every takes e5 k7 right now this
king comes towards this pawn
and black simply wins
black simply wins but this is not the
end of the drama
because the game was still uh there was
still like i think one or two important
ones in this end game
supposedly what is just being fisher
with black
winning position winning end game should
win right
uh well there was some
there was some interesting stuff going
on so let's see what happened
uh king g3 you know interesting uh
defensive idea basically active but very
logical activate the king from the king
side
but you play basically play king h4k g5
maybe get towards h7
maybe if black king goes towards you
know c6 but maybe we can get towards f6
square and get e5 pawn or something like
that
of course it is not sufficient black is
winning but let's see what happened
so in the game follow king d7 king h4
king c6
king g5 and right now i think the
one of the simplest paths to win was
simply king takes c5
and after king f6 bishop just go back to
d7 king e5 and
a5 4 by king c4 pawn polling a4 is lost
you cannot defend pawn only four because
i'm gonna play king c4 on the next move
and uh you know as i collect pawn on e4
my a pawn will go to the queen and you
know it's kind of like a saying in
polish
uh that just saying in polish sort of
like a phrase
that uh knight sorry is like a horsey
sort of
and has short legs so basically it will
not be able to catch the
advanced pawn on the other side of the
board right now like this a pawn will
basically has
like bishop let's say has a much longer
range right so
but nice doesn't uh nice don't have such
a range that's why
uh it will pretty much uh be very
difficult for this knight to you know
defend here
and essentially black is just winning uh
so this was the easiest a however player
playing with e4 which also
should which is also winning but it's
less clear because right now in such end
games
the best way in general is to try to
simplify the position
it's a precisely what well uh
what ulman is doing he played move g4
ft hg4 and knight xe4 he
got one he got a pair of puns traded so
it's definitely uh you know success
right now a5 and the king f4
so right now what would you play right
now with black it's a very important
position what would you play here with
black
i think one of the two positions i
wanted to give you to think about
there is there is i will explain
so what to do here with black
bishop d5 uh
h5 h6
okay king d5 has someone as well
okay
yeah this is interesting what you're
suggesting we should be free okay
i was expecting this at some point we
should be free again
okay so many different suggestions many
different suggestions
and all those moves are possible at
first it seems right
but only two of them win
and bishop d5 is not one of them so
after bishop d5
basically i can play knight f6
to be sure if i go knight f6 i started
chasing both people's pawns
after king c5 i play king e3 and
basically
you know i'm attacking those two pawns
you cannot defend both
i bri i mean time to bring my king
quickly to the king side
and i will try to give up my uh after
bringing my king to the you know
to towards the square i will try to i
will capture one of these pawns and i
will try to give
you know my knight for another pawn and
will be at that draw
that's the main thing that's the draw
issue this is the drawing strategy right
now
so uh i think this is this is not
sufficient for for a win
but the the winning idea right now is to
play simply move h5
and after a move this is the thing the
cleanest h6 also
does it but it's a little bit less clear
and
there's does it bishop a3 still win uh
it doesn't it doesn't because after
bishop f3
i'm gonna capture on h7 if you take here
uh i guess i simply go back to the g5
or even f6 yeah i should do f6 just to
f6
and uh yeah just take this pawn sorry
and you know it's like a race who's
gonna be faster i think i'm actually
going to be faster with my pawn if we
give you to track my knight
so it's not so clear it's not so clear
so the best move here is simply h5
h5 is the best move because after knight
f6 usually bishop f7
we protect those two pawns
and because this king is so far away you
know even after hd4 king is so far away
from the
a1 square uh this is not sufficient for
for a draw and that's why playing this
[ __ ] before wiki there is no way to
stop this
and okay let's say you give knight e4
bishop g6 or something
and this is not this is this is uh
winning for black easily
so uh let's see what happened in the
game fall bishop be free and this is a
huge mistake which is basically
and but but this is like
i thought at first it's also winning at
first i also
i thought at first it's also there's
winning but it's not
it's that's why i wanted to really show
you this i think it's crazy why
uh to find to realize that this is not
uh winning
because i mean it seems like it's
winning right
and right now king e3 bishop takes a4
and rhino very important with king d2
king goes back to the king side
an idea is to play knight f6 to give to
you know take attack this pawn
one of these pawns and yeah for instance
right now
you know if you check this with engine
code engine will be showing like plus
three plus four i mean minus three minus
four or something even more
for uh for white four for black but
it is but in reality it's everywhere
it's draw
because for instance after bishop d3 is
one of the computer suggestions let's
say knight f6
attack involves two pawns uh bishop b6
now we take this pawn
and computer still doesn't see that this
is a draw which is crazy to me
modern engines three thousand five
hundred six hundred level right
and they don't see like that this is
it's computer suggestions so this is a
draw
like come on this is just that draw
right
and uh they uh i know it's still show
like
this black is winning all of this
they're going to they're going to go for
this position in many very many
variations
i was like what's going on and uh
finally at first i thought that okay h6
should still win and this is what
because this is what fischer did
and h6 suppose uh is supposed to be
winning at first
seems like because after knight f6 king
c59 g4
h5 basically uh you know
after you you know let's say um
okay actually this position i mean at
first it seems like okay why this black
is still winging because you know the
there is um you know the knight will not
capture this pawn on h5
right and if it doesn't capture then
okay a pawn goes to the queen or
at least destructs black king or knight
and then king goes to the king's side
and that's it
so uh finally here
finally here what would you play with
white question is whether knight
e3 or knight f6 93 or knight f6 what do
you guys think
one of it was one of those moves loses
one of them wins
okay uh i had some
some okay like 50 50 and pretty much
this is like
a coincidence decision yes uh i mean
it's either coin flip
or you just calculate everything
perfectly but i know it's very difficult
to
play some of this very very accurately
but yes it is a draw
and the point is that you gotta play
knight f6
uh it's more force attacks pawn on h5
because let's see what happens further
than 83 after 93 basically the game is
just over after king d4
neither one trying to get this through
this pawn but again just kinky five
avoiding any checks
we should be free and uh basically a
pawn goes and
that's it that's it that's very simple
there is nothing to discuss it's 9g3
here i i know i guess it was maybe the
game was adjourned or something
i don't know and you know they didn't
continue but here i guess we again the
game ended but anyway
black is just winning here even i think
uh a4 could win but also h4
uh you know is just just winning a four
should be winning
uh a four lane h5 three ninety four
eight yeah is also winning
so either a4 or h4 i mean anything is
just winning
uh but knight f6 let's let's i'll
discuss knight f6
on f6 i was able to share what i
discovered uh
h4 and now back knight g4
and suddenly it's not easy to make
progress here with white
because the knight goes to where's both
squares where from where it will
harass this hhh pawn and you it appears
that
black can at least i couldn't find maybe
i missed something but at least what i
analyzed i couldn't find anything
here for for black for instance uh after
analyze three moves king d4 can be
decent king c4 after let's say king d4
after king d4 uh i was thinking just
lighting simulates 93
okay right now 95 is a big threat
if king e4 uh there is this problem that
suddenly knight c4 will go from this
side
that's the point that's the big big
point
that because right now we are going
after the apoll and if so therefore you
cannot go k4 and otherwise we're gonna
stop these moves
so it seems like this is the move or
some uh or bishop c6 let's say
uh and after this but you know we take
this pawn and okay this is just the draw
after king of six engines claims that
this is winning for black because uh you
know the knight is trapped because
it doesn't go here but of course we
don't care about it's just king c3 right
and just go here and okay just draw
right away
here we go so uh this is one thing king
d4 is one possibility
it doesn't doesn't lead anywhere another
possibility is what analyzes
bishop d7 and again just 95 and we
should
hear okay just knight of three okay just
like g5 king goes you know here
or something or sorry uh right away king
c3 and
there is no way to stop this king b2 and
draw right away as well
uh um bishop d7 i just i just analyzed
all right so uh after energy for
what else i also asked king c4 i thought
this was pretty tricky
and uh i think here or there's only one
way to make a draw
uh i think knight
e wait i need let me
because i i have two moves i don't
really remember
hold on if the king c4 uh
i think 95 i think 95 i think 95
because after uh let's say king b for
king b4 i go knight f3
and again something like this is a draw
why only moves
because after this bishop before
seemingly designed is trapped right
uh but again we just go here and after
king b3 seemingly black wins because
okay now
the king knight is trapped king cargo
get to b1 but we just play knight f3
and after bishop takes the three can be
one draw a grid
right so uh kim b3 was supposedly a
better move
but anyway here is sort of like the
similar thing because at 93 bishop b5
analyzed
at h4 a4 and king is starting time to
get there
and if bishop defeated knight comes to
the game without the 392 and stuff
so uh after this i think this is simply
a draw as well because now it's in time
to get there
so basically to the last tempo but uh
basically you know black and black so
white can save this
which is nuts uh to you know to find
mirror such miraculous draw in this
position
but yeah this is with what hit what
happens
yeah so that's all i had for today uh
i think it was very very interesting
especially really figuring out that this
end game is suddenly a drone
i found it you know personally very
interesting so
i hope you find it interesting too okay
that's all i have for today
uh take care guys i will
uh i think it was my last lecture for
for my gym residence for now
uh tomorrow however i'll have some more
stream on twitch
so stay tuned for that feel free to join
all right take care guys uh good night
i'll talk to you next time a good one
have a good one